[موسيقى]
من كسروات نورنا في شمال بيروت مراسلت
صباح العربيه رينا دويهي رينا اهلا بك
نورتينا حدثيني اكثر من قصه الامثال اللي
كنا بنشوفها مع بعض خلاص
صباح الخير
هو استاذ الفلسفه وهو قبل كل شيء عاشق
للطبيعه وللمشي في ربوعها هذه الروايه
التي حولها شربل الى مصدر للدخل بعد ان
توجهها الى تصنيع عصا يدويه بطريقه
انحرفيه هذه العسل التي يجمعها من احراج
اللبنانيه في مختلف رحلته الاستكشافيه
صباح الخير شربل جميل جدا هذه المجموعه
التي همم التي اراها هنا يمكن اكثر
ملفاتني هيدا العسل للتحمل توقيع مختلف
البلدات اللي انت زرتها شفت مختلف الكره
اللبنانيه منحوت همم ومنكوشه هنا هلال
الوحده الاولى انا ماشي في الضيعه اهدر مع
انه لازم تكون همم
خبرني بالبدايه كيف وصلت لهون
انا مثل ما قلت انا عاشق للطبيعه وانا
دائما ضل رحلات استكشفيه من طلع على كل
مناطق بلبنان وبمشي وخلال جوله الماشي تبع
جوله ماشي حبات العسل
[موسيقى]
ذكرني بمشوار معين صارت تربطني بالعصايه
وقررت ان يشارك هالهويه مع اشخاص ثانيين
حبوا كمان يكون عندهم علاقه مع الاعصاب
حولت من الروايه
من بعد شويه على النار
[موسيقى]
يعني بتبطل عصا جلسه تصلح للمشي بعد فتره
اربعه اشهر بصير فينا انا اقدر احفرها
وزينا اخر شيء بيننا تضل همم نعطيها كمان
تونس ضايل مع الايد ومع الاستعمال ومع
الماء والشتاء والهوى اليوم للعصر رمزيه
كبيره يعني هي موجوده بالكتب الدينيه
موجوده بتاريخ الحضارات وموجوده ايضا
وبكثره بالامثله الشعبيه اللبنانيه حدثنا
اكثر
من اول ما وجه الانسان لليوم لا مش من
زمان كثير وقف يستعمل العصا كان همم
ادوات يعني همم كل الحضاراتنا بالكتابه
المقدس في الخروج والسفر التكوين على
اليوم اذا بدك
شغله ما معي مصاري رومانسي
بالكتابه بالعربي
فالعصا دخلت مع اللي دخلت بفكر الانسان
لفتره كثير طويله بس بدك نحكي بشكل مختصر
عن لبنان احنا بلبنان نحنا الامثله نحنا
اولاد جبال في لبنان وطلع عمرنا مستعمل
عصا للمعذور للربش بنعوزه بحياتنا اليوميه
راحت الحياه اليوميه اللي كنا نعيشه دي
حقيقه الطبيعه وظلت العصاره
مثلا العصب تعلم
العصر من نصها ما بيعرف من العسل كل هذه
بتختصر الشعب اللبناني اللي استعمل
الرموز وطبيعه حياتي اللي كان هو يعيشها
بحياته اليوميه الجبليه
ونقول ايضا العصا لمن عصا مع انني انا ضد
هذا هذه المقوله بكل الاحوال عوده لكم الى
الاستديو شكرا لك يا رينا وشكرا لضيفك
شكرا لكم